[Music]
Brazil the land of Carnival Samba Soccer
and oil indeed visual party Community
Brazil is not only the Cradle of the
Amazon the lungs are Planet but also one
of the world's largest oil producers as
well as the largest producer in all of
Latin America in fact in 2022 Brazil
produced more than four percent of all
the oil extracted in the world therefore
it is not surprising that it rubs
shoulders with major oil producers in
the Middle East such as Kuwait Iran or
the United Arab Emirates even so Brazil
is not only constantly on the lips of
analysts because of its strong oil
possession less than a year ago Latin
America's largest economy made headlines
around the world because of news like
this Brazil presidential election Lula
defeats bolsonaro by Thin margin indeed
Lula who has been considered by many as
the rock star of the left in Latin
America returned to Power by a very
narrow margin in the elections against
former president bolsonaro Trump's Ally
Who also failed to extend his mandate
[Music]
and as many of you will remember this
also caused one of the most unfortunate
incidents in Brazilian history a bunch
of citizens unhappy with the outcome
took a cue from the United States and
stormed the nation's Congress apparently
that's just a thing that happens now
however luckily they achieved little
more than being arrested and some were
injured because in the reality Lula had
one and in January of this year he
assumed power since then Lula has
emphasized social and above all
environmental measures therefore many
fear that with the third Lula presidency
the end of Brazilian oil has come after
all this is exactly the path followed by
Gustavo Petros Colombia the point is
that all of this has made us on
visualpolitik wonder about a few things
how did Brazil become an oil power what
role did oil play in Lula's first two
presidencies will Lula changed his
position on oil to comply with the
climate agenda will this be the
beginning of the end of Brazilian oil
today we're going to answer all of these
questions but first let's look at some
history
[Music]
thank you
a long road
[Music]
how long do you think it took Brazil to
become one of the major oil Powers I'm
sure many of you will think that as soon
as oil was found money started just
pouring in from all directions but the
reality is that like Rome oil producing
Brazil was not built in a day the road
to becoming one of the 10 largest oil
producing Powers was full of failures
and above all was long more than a whole
Century since its first oil exploration
you see after gaining independence in
1822 the first barrels of oil were not
extracted in Brazil until 1892 with
Eugenio Ferrer de Camargo although only
two barrels were extracted nevertheless
with this first extraction the Brazilian
State realized the enormous potential of
its subsoil and in the beginning of the
20th century the public initiative
joined the private sector in the search
for commercial oil fields in 1907 the
Brazilian government created the
geological and mineralogical service of
Brazil which drilled 60 whales in search
of oil although it wasn't that
successful however in 1941 with the help
of the newly created National Petroleum
Council the first commercial well was
finally established but the country's
production was still not abundant by the
end of the 1940s Brazil was only
producing 2 700 barrels per day at a
time when its domestic demand was more
than 170 000 barrels per day due to the
industrialization process that the
country was undergoing
[Music]
nevertheless this was to begin to change
with the birth of Brazil's major oil
player in 1953 the Brazilian government
founded a company that would shape the
state's Monopoly on oil research
drilling refining and transportation
Patrol
s a better known as petrobras was born
many of you already know that today
petrobras is Brazil's most important
company but did you know that it spent
its first 15 years of existence being
almost totally unproductive the truth is
visual politic viewers it was not until
1968 the petrobras made its first
discovery the guarasima field although
this would seem like nothing compared to
the two Fields it discovered six years
later in the Campos Basin the garupa and
Pargo Fields now do you think that
Brazil was all set to become the oil
power it is today well nothing could be
further from the truth
by 1980 Brazilian production only
covered 17 of domestic demand therefore
that same year the government set a goal
of 500 thousand barrels per day of
production by 1985 yet it was not until
the 1995 constitutional reform that the
Brazilian oil sector really began to
bear fruit this reform opened the sector
to private competition lifted
restrictions on the entry of foreign
capital and more importantly ended the
Monopoly of petrobras which became a
semi-public company with the majority of
shares in the hands of the state
with this change production increased
and Brazil achieved the longed force
self-sufficiency in the early 2000s
however more than a century had passed
since that first small oil extraction in
1892 and Brazil was still not in the top
10 of the great oil Powers but that
would change with the arrival of one of
the most significant figures in Latin
American politics Louise Ignacio Lula de
Silva
[Music]
thank you
Lula the lucky one
[Music]
in order for your name to go down in
politics history it is often not about
having the best managers but it is also
about being lucky and Lula and his first
two presidencies was lucky you see the
Brazilian leader who won his first
presidential elections in 2002 managed
to lead Brazil through a period of
prosperity not so much because of his
impeccable management of the economy but
above all because of several lucky
bricks the most important of which was
this one Brazil discovers country's
largest oil field indeed visual politic
viewers in 2007 one of the largest oil
fields in the country and indeed in the
world was discovered the 2p field a
field with reserves of about 29 billion
barrels of oil this would finally Place
Brazil among the 10 largest oil
producers in the world now Lula was no
fool the cost was not going to be low in
2010 he passed laws so that part of the
company's profits would go to the public
coffers in addition it is also true that
he benefited petrobrass with which he
signed an agreement allowing it to
exploit an produce up to 5 billion
barrels of oil for 40 years but even
with all this his luck did not end there
think about it Lula came to power in a
time of certain stability his
predecessor managed to tame inflation
and avoid a major recession but most
importantly of all Lula came right in
the middle of the well-known commodity
super cycle a time when commodity prices
were skyrocketing
in fact with the arrival of Lula the
trade surplus went from 10 billion
dollars in 2002 to 47 billion dollars in
2007 thanks to the discovery of the oil
field and the high costs of raw
materials so let's just say it's no
wonder that the country grew at an
average of 4.5 per year during his first
two presidencies and do you know what he
did with all the money he managed to
raise well in short he extended social
programs or to put it another way he
enlarged the size of the state Lula
launched programs such as Balsa Familia
which gave monthly Aid to the poorest
families in the country or hambre zero a
campaign that aimed to reduce the number
of people who were going hungry and to
be perfectly honest they were a great
success
as you can see the percentage of the
Brazilian population in poverty fell by
more than 15 percentage points between
2001 and 2011 both because of the Bolsa
Familia program which benefited 12.4
million households and because of the
increase in the employed population from
17 7 million to more than 90 million
people and not only that Lula also began
to promote measures for the protection
of the environment particularly against
the deforestation of the Amazon to give
you an idea the area deforested annually
between 2000 and 2005 was 34 700
kilometers squared an area almost
equivalent to the size of Switzerland
however from 2005 until the end of his
presidency this was reduced to 4500
kilometers squared per year at the time
Lula was tremendously committed to the
protection of the Amazon but his fight
against greenhouse gas emissions caused
by hydrocarbons such as oil and gas was
not as strong so why was this well for
one simple reason Lula is what is known
as in oil nationalist so what does this
mean basically he cannot conceive of
Brazil's progress without oil
nevertheless 13 years after the end of
his second presidency Lula has returned
to the political scene it's a very
different political scenario than the
one he encountered previously for
example today the fight for the
reduction of greenhouse gas emissions is
much more intense so you might ask well
Lula given to the demands of the climate
agenda to the detriment of his people
could we be looking at the end of the
oil industry in Brazil well let's find
out
[Music]
Lula's decision
Lula's return to power was a relief for
much of the International Community who
were concerned about bolsonaro's
environmental mismanagement in Brazil it
should be noted that he closed several
nature protection agencies such as the
Chico Mendes Institute he reduced
spending on climate change mitigation
policies by 93 and deforestation was a
rampant in several parts of the country
in some places deforestation grew by 34
during his presidency nevertheless
although many have rejoiced at Lulu's
return the reality is that the scenario
is not as favorable as in his first
cycle the Congress is dominated by
bolsonarus the effects of the pandemic
are still being felt especially with a
debt that has reached 88 percent of GDP
poverty levels are still around 30 and
interest rates are stuck at 13.75
percent something that has led Lula to
an all-out confrontation with the
central bank and to top it all off the
country's growth projections are not the
best either in fact Brazil is expected
to grow more than half a point behind
the rest of Latin America and the
Caribbean however Against All Odds the
Brazilian economy me has actually been a
surprise Brazil's economy improves under
Lula defies Central Bank rates a rebound
in Brazil's Agriculture and a strong
labor market helped deliver far better
results than economists had forecast at
the start of 2023.
[Music]
in addition during these first months of
his new presidency Lula has promoted
several reforms reminiscent of his first
two presidencies for example he has
reopened to the Balsa Familia program
that bolsonaro closed in 2021 and
reinstated the national food Security
Council meanwhile on the environmental
front he reopened the Amazon fund signed
laws to seize illegally deforested land
and reopened the Balsa Verde program
which gives money to poor families
living in traditional communities who
are responsible for protecting the
environment
in general these measures contribute to
Brazil's repositioning as a leader in
the environmental struggle even so the
question many are asking is is Lula
willing to emulate Gustavo Petro to go
one step further and do away with
national oil well the truth is that the
chances of Lula sacrificing the
Brazilian oil industry to achieve this
goal are rather low if not non-existent
Moola described Gustavo Petro's proposal
to suspend oil production as unreal
former Brazilian president Louise
Ignacio Lula de Silva assured that the
use of hydrocarbons is still necessary
in the world and gave as an example the
situation in Germany in fact if Lula has
already managed to place Brazil among
the world's top 10 oil producers his
goal now is to make it the world's
fourth largest producer of all of them
for this reason petrobras expects to
increase daily production from three to
five million barrels by 2030 and not
only that the Brazilian oil giant is
also trying to get a license to be able
to drill in the Amazon basin an area
where there are estimated reserves of up
to 30 billion barrels of oil and where
it is willing to invest six billion
dollars in Exploration alone over the
next five years
[Music]
added to this is the fact that between
2022 and now Brazil has approved the
largest number of oil and gas projects
behind only Saudi Arabia and Qatar and
this is not so unusual just remember the
projections indicate that petrobras will
provide more than 200 billion dollars in
revenues to the state coffers in the
next five years 200 billion dollars that
Lula is counting on to carry out his
social policies you see visual party
Community it does not appear that Brazil
is going to break with its oil tradition
with Lula in reality it seems that
exactly the opposite will happen his oil
gamble will become even stronger yes it
is true he has restored initiatives to
fight against factors contributing to
climate change such as deforestation but
oil exploration in Brazil seems
non-negotiable especially if Lula wants
to maintain his social spending of
course the environment is one of Lula's
priorities but at the end of the day
Petro dollars continue to dominate the
scale of those priorities but at this
point the questions are now over to you
do you think that Lula will ultimately
reduce the influence of the oil industry
in Brazil what position do you think
Lula had on the oil industry you can
leave me your answers in the comments
below and as always don't forget the
here on visualpolitik we release new
videos every single week subscribe to
this channel hit the little bell button
down there so you don't miss any of our
updates if you like this video like it
so we know all the best I hope you
enjoyed it
see you next time
[Music]